at school tests and grades are meant to
show our progress towards gaining
practical skills or understanding
complicated ideas unfortunately they
often measure the wrong thing or a
limited form of progress Albert Einstein
said any fool can know the point is to
understand and he was right
there is no point in knowing what a
solar panel is if we don't know why it
was built or how to install it too often
tests focus on the watt
rather than the more important questions
of how or why multiple-choice is
especially tricky governments and
schools love it because you can compute
the results fast and cheap unfortunately
multiple-choice does not measure for
creativity or original thoughts as long
as test scores assess only one very
limited form of understanding there will
be parents and teachers that push
children to focus on the wrong things
facts for example as long as kids have
to study subjects not aligned with the
personal interest boredom confusion or
low self-confidence will prevail
psychologist Angela Duckworth says
character perseverance and mindset make
all the difference in school work and
life she calls it grit
famous neuroscientist manfred Spitzer
argues the most important subjects to
become good at anything include music
handcrafting and drama which are
difficult to measure with tests some top
schools already focus on mindset or
teach Theatre in the West Montessori and
Waldorf schools help children to develop
practical creative and social skills
whilst grades matter little in East Asia
there's a new breed of Buddhist schools
that focus on character empathy
awareness and mindset what do you think
is it an accident that the visionary
founders of Google Wikipedia and Amazon
or went to Montessori a school that
doesn't use grades